[Music]
I always say start by being curious I
think about it in four steps and step
one is ask ask a question you actually
want to know the answer to and one that
you might be willing to share a little
information on as well you want to ask
an open-ended question to get somebody
talking and when you're thinking about
well what do I ask a question about well
you can think about the environment
you're in you can think about the event
you're at you can think about the
geographic region hey you know any good
restaurants in the area you can think
about what's in the news right now and
you never know where they might lead and
that's where if part two comes in part
two is listen and probe or listen and
share so listen and probe obviously the
key is listen right because you're
asking a question you you need to not
think about what you need to say next
you need to think about what are they
saying and where could that conversation
take us they've said something that
you're curious about
keep going probe a little further be
careful not to interrogate it's not
machine gun questions at somebody but
it's a probing question to learn a
little bit more and then interject with
listen and share so you can create those
you to meet to moments of sharing your
perspective or your experience or your
ideas on whatever that topic might be
three is to look and connect in connect
we're looking for those similarities
those commonalities what makes us say I
want to continue this relationship what
is the you - me - moment because people
like people like them and they like
people who they have associations with
so do we have common interests do we
have common values do we have common
experiences do we have common goals
- we have common needs and really look
for surprised commonalities they're not
always there and obvious on the surface
I always say call out the similarities
not the differences when you are in
stage three this is when you're thinking
about what's our next point of contact
what did we talk about that I might be
able to follow up with did they need a
plumber for that weather happening do
they need information about a place
they're going on vacation and I might
have a travel agent or a hotel
recommendation what was it that you
talked about they can leave the next
point of contact and if it was
something specific well we always have
just connecting virtually link into them
or connect them on whatever social
platform that they are on and once we
have that next point of contact we're
ready for step four of the conversation
which is actually the clothes when you
close the conversation down
be sure to manage the mood memory mood
memory is how somebody feels they don't
remember what you said but they remember
how they felt in the conversation with
you
and you want to make sure that you don't
ruin that wood memory right at the end
when you're looking at your watch or
over the shoulder trying to think about
how do I get out of this think about an
exit strategy that maintains that energy
that you created in the conversation a
couple of my favorites are asking them
to see if they want to drink hey I'm
gonna go grab a drink would you like one
they may come with you they may not but
in that movement you enable other things
to happen within the conversation or
natural separation it might be a trip to
the restroom which most the time they
won't follow you but you never know with
women we like to go in pairs it could be
hey you know it was great chatting looks
like somebody over there would like to
join our conversation let's go and bite
them in and it wouldn't be that you're
ending that conversation is that you're
expanding it
[Music]